[Applause]
oh i'm so pumped up dessert is the only
thing that i eat
this is an awesome challenge because
they're really outside their comfort
zone also they have to put on a little
show for us right and the flavors got to
be there too i cannot wait to see the
creativity there's nine desserts yeah
[Music]
what's on the menu are you ready to try
something oh thank you it's a fun one
yeah
who's ready for dessert uh all right
hey we gotta have more ice
all right smack it
whoa
look at the ice we made a red velvet
cake with a spicy cayenne infused cream
cheese frosting and we did the
strawberry tong hulu on the top because
it kind of looks like the strawberries
encased in ice and then for the fire we
did the red velvet and there's cayenne
presentation is fire thank you
oh it's strawberry candy
i really like the presentation there
that ice that was fun it was like a
showstopper but the cake is too much
sugar i couldn't eat much more than i
already ate of it and i only ate two
bites of it i just wanted more of the
cayenne
help me how am i supposed to help you
hello eva and jen let me try to scoop oh
my god this is so from the bottom i'm
trying to the ice cream is melting
oh my god
we made you a sticky toffee pudding and
caramelized blow torch peaches with a
cinnamon espresso ice cream thank you
guys
we're excited eat it quickly
i love the thematics of the sticker
toffee but the tuffy cake is dry inside
but the ice cream to make it with liquid
nitrogen and the texture to be that
great captures the challenge but i'm
missing that fire
the presentation was very uncomfortable
yeah i love them and i know that they're
full of chaos but i don't want to see it
yeah
[Music]
hi kai and luke hello we did a spin on
new orleans beignets and coffee we made
a coffee milkshake with a liquid
nitrogen then we have the hot beige with
a cinnamon powdered sugar dust and you
gotta shake it
so excited let's go shake it in thanks
guys
oh my god
it smells so good i just want to send it
coffee milkshake oh my god that's the
most delicious thing i've ever had oh
man the presentation is fun it's not the
best pinata i've ever had not as light
and fluffy but the flavors are there
yeah overall fire and ice they did a
good job i think for sure
hi danny and delilah hi
we have a cold sun as we like to call it
it's a cold mango mousse chamoy filling
inside almond aqua cake on the bottom so
right now it's about noon we're gonna
put it to sunset
i love it so now it's sunset so this is
just a mixture of sprinkles and chili
powder you're bringing the hair
beautiful i got some glitter for you
jojo yeah
thank you judges
so fancy
whoa wait a second stunning
oh it's so good i love it the textures
it's gooey it's creamy that cross
section and that's like what it's all
about it makes me feel like i'm at a
really fancy restaurant and i just paid
56 for this i'm loving this challenge i
like this it's good right
all right screaming a little bit runny
it's like a sauce
oh my god this ice cream is not holding
up you freeze it put it in the last
piece and come careful put your hand
directly under it
where's the lighter
ocean and jd what did you make for us
the name of our dish is a battle of the
goddesses
on the bottom we got a coconut tres
leche cake on top of that is a blue
vanilla mac nut ice cream and on top of
that is a passion fruit curd popped off
with a little bit of coconut and who
doesn't like a little rum with that oh
they got the fire yeah
oh yes this is what i'm talking about
fire and ice heck yeah oh wow
guys beautiful thank you
oh my god it's just getting better and
better the presentation is amazing oh
so refreshing i'm still reversing i'm in
hawaii on the beach i love things that
are sour and it's just good that passion
fruit curd on top it is sour it's tart
but you need that to get the ice cream
so it's so smart
you